yeah hello and welcome to this video
round eight played today on sunday of
tata steel 2013 so I'll go through the
games but I'll warn you in advance that
that it will be a little bit quicker and
less detailed and usual because I had to
gain myself today play to draw in the
german league it wasn't so interesting
to show the game but it still was a long
day with the drive during during
snowstorms and whatever so it's a little
bit shorter than usual so let's start
and I'll pick the first game what let's
let's do this one Giri against long how
ya do off two of the tail enders in this
Donald both are not having a great
tournament Giri already am lost down
three games two or three games and wow
how just lost yesterday terribly tuna
camera so i guess they both um didn't
mind to have a quiet game so laughs and
one whole place was g6 this accords left
arm variation selective re-enter of
Dodge okay so um it's a very solid set
up for black with g6 and the main idea
has to get the bishop out the light
squared Bishop it gets exchanged and now
blacks setup is like this he's got all
pawns basically on the light squares
sometimes he even plays a six has the
bishop on g7 and this is as solid as it
can get very hard to break down this
position this is always also favored of
gotta come ski so so really making a
living out of without of playing this is
black and not losing and sometimes eaten
winning okay so um what is White's plan
you can play for space it
vantage with c5 and probably f4 I can
play for reform the other point is black
can play a five film himself in the game
will see that after some typical
strengthening moves like decided to take
and play you five this is actually um
yeah relatively ambitious approach who
have like in comparison it also could
just sit and wait we get this kind of
setup white played c5 to make some room
for his bishop but on the other hand his
be to bishop isn't so great we have with
94 some exchanges and here it's already
um um yeah quite apparent that it's
difficult for white to get something is
I got no problem break d5 maybe but the
problem is that defaults a weakness and
a couple of moves later we see that
black firmly blocks d5 and also has that
this weakness securely protected and
here we are already close to to a draw
as both sides don't have much ideas to
get forward and we had some exchange
here like gets of the c5 pawn yeah also
take c5 as possible but Bishop e8 maybe
yeah this is probably easier attacking
those two pawns cheetah just check on
the chief later when they also draw a
greet so yeah it's a perpetual either so
I guess both players content with the
draw this setup this variation here can
be recommended for black players who
really want a very solid set up it's
hard to break down but difficult to do
something with I guess after this loss
long how I wasn't too too disappointed
with the draw
okay let's go next game let's do island
against sokoloff so zocalo from being a
the tail end of the tournament the down
and close to the lead so subdivision
wants to get something going we got a
ruler PES and local off place f5 the
shame and gambit or yanush gambit um
yeah very good very good line for black
hood serve in great theoretical shape
and gives black opportunities to ya get
white on some some terrain that you
maybe doesn't know so well of course a
normal game is not in world-class games
they certainly know what to do it you
can install surprise people with that 50
k 93 is the main line you took and 9th
f6 this is the way this is played
nowadays the old move d 5 which can lead
to crazy complications after Knight
takes and and this um yeah they don't
think it's really refuted but nowadays
people almost exclusively play Knight f6
this is the way I play this myself as
black I sometimes play f5 as a surprise
weapon um okay queenie to hear i
actually played d 5 which is some
probably the main move at soccer Lofton
didn't go for that d5 candy to keep
something like this yeah I don't want to
make a theoretical survey out of this
it's entirely different look at all
played Queenie seven which I just
checked in in the database which is
really am a move but I never knew this
existed you've not only new g5 but it
seems to be a quite okay for black
castles t5 so black delayed this move
for ya for you from now we have the same
structure as mentioned before Black has
got quite imposing porn
but the problem is he still suffers from
this pin and from of course in somewhat
weak in position Donna tries to open up
the position instantly getting this kind
of idea into play f5 yeah like protect
this on laterally of Queen h5 just Queen
f7 and it's not much not much happening
really no it's um it's quite interesting
to play this way as black but of course
I'm a bit risky yeah yeah well now the
night is hanging and why just protected
it should be seven c3d force was also
hanging and at some point it needs
protection and now black manages to
castle so certainly am physical offer
could be quite content with the with the
opening result y term didn't didn't
really get something okay f3 trying to
chip away at the center but yeah simply
a normal development it's okay for back
here actually check sokoloff plate this
somewhat shocking move Bishop takes d4
and I don't think it was really
necessary but it seems to be fine it
yeah it's simply initiates a technical
sequence why I took it otherwise you're
just a pawn down Knight takes and now we
see that there's a double attack Queen
d2 this is the point Queen a 90 x b5 it
was hanging so need to capture and now
white x ESO lo sokoloff had to calculate
this tactical sequence and it seems to
lead to a pretty draws position but um I
guess I didn't have much yeah I did much
chance to play something else to keep on
fighting he played rook to e1 he could
take on b7 this is something you could
think about but it looks somewhat
strange let's say Queens check
King here the ship II and the queen is
almost wrapped work c1 the Sun may be an
idea but I don't think you really am
have something at the end let's say
queen takes you one cheat me take Sayed
you should i head over here and it takes
and I don't really think that white is
playing for win here of course I'm like
has some only isolated form so what's
always it was also not possible probably
would like to do anything but suddenly
white cannot go for wing here yeah he
played rugby one and in fact after
rookie 80 sorry hit the wrong button
rook e8 he play tonight x f5 just
liquidating the position simply because
I'm why doesn't have anything and
potentially he needs to be careful with
the somewhat offside night on h4 so this
simplifies some the game to a draw check
yeah and draw a grid yes certainly a
good result for the cool off but he's
really am yeah a pretty good player I
mean last place is somewhat some but um
worse then he's capable off and if he if
you get a good those guys was 26
something players to 670 get a good
position out of the opening and they
have good chances to to score points
against even the best in the world and
this was certainly a good result maybe
this Queenie 7 moved from surprised
aren't hard to tell if there was hard to
tell what lines are cut off is going to
play in the and the way he plays all
lines basically okay so draw here for
vision
so next game how Krishna against lake oh
I'm here the because surprise for me was
that nickel plate played the night off
which I didn't really knew Letty that
he's playing this I knew of the chashni
cup of course and the night off yeah
maybe I'm simply not up to date but I
was really surprised to see that you
hired Krishna played Bishop e3 here the
old move from Bishop g5 nowadays is back
on the theoretical on a limelight with
the e 6f for Queen B 6 and those kind of
lines but how I Krishna plays Bishop e3
initiating the the model main line so to
save me 59 to be three we should be 6 cm
and here the the main set up SF 3 energy
form a typical English attack formation
and Queen d2 castles long castles but
high Krishna and play something
different and it's an interesting set of
a place h3 bishop in seven Queen f3 this
sound has become popular lately the idea
is to quickly get the Queen out prepare
casting this way and then probably play
d4 d5 h4 very quickly this is exactly
what happened before 95 yeah this all
looks fairly typical for for the night
off he took with the night which is
probably the right decision and now
dropped all the way back okay it looks
good we had to UM get him to go and come
back to see eight but I think you cannot
tolerate the 90 m on d5 you need to
capture it and you don't really want to
take it with the bishop this kind of
position looks very good for white with
g5 h4 Bishop d3 and without a light
squared Bishop this is simply not fun to
play
so this is correct i guess and you
should be 30 50 fairly logical yeah now
white regroups the night maybe using it
on a forum on the kingside in general
but nico played Bishop g5 feel very
logical some a bank bed peace only seven
and young black ones to exchange it I
think in all in all this is a very a
very straightforward and logical game
and five of course h7 you need to attend
to the main thread and f5 leads to a
change of the pawn structure as we will
see soon exactly like this and here the
typical feature of these structures that
white will get a knight on e4 which will
let's put it on the board always it take
t6 and what black has got in return is
some some play on the f porn and maybe
the H porn and this probably cancelled
each other out rook a 62 to cover d6 and
now 97 if the nights off then black him
probably is even slightly better so this
is what white needs to take care of his
six was saying so route 36 g 3g 6 yeah
black cam has no easy way to to get rid
of the Knights this is a problem queen
three attacking the rook and we have a
queen trade and white even tries to get
rid of this rock like a break up a black
drop back check and now we have the
mentioned trade off lights and here the
game was was a great drawn actually am
and this is the position a position
where I think black could try to
play on for a bit c 2 and F to look look
weaker let's say then then maybe g66 is
hard to get Edward you can play against
the CNF con it's a it's draw I shall no
doubt about that but if someone can
contrive in this game in this position
then it is black and um you know you can
easily imagine yeah and our times that
player like ours will play this against
to 650 26 every 80 game probably win
some of these some of these positions um
yeah but like it doesn't have much what
I think you could could try to play on
ok draw a greet ok now let's have a look
at aronian against we fond of course
them this is a game that player like
Aronian must try to win if he wants to
fight for for the win in this tournament
yesterday sport I'm win against kayaking
with black and now certainly wants to
win year UNC for aronian sometimes place
you fall and we get the so-called
Makino's variation with c4 84 yeah this
is fairly in fairly interesting on for
white and actually I always believed
that white um can fight for an advantage
in this and this is opening this is also
why 90 f 686 instant so popular on among
top players because they want to avoid
this eve online otherwise this would
certainly be a popular move order SD for
let's say the alternatives yeah night
f.3d five leads to a Queens gambit
declined would sure it's quite popular
Bishop before it's ok and if white would
play d4 instantly then you get an Enzo
also great so this would be a popular
move order but before some
I'd issue for black and it's not like
white is clearly better but white has
more chances to fight for an advantage
in this opening then in many other lines
ok d5 is the main reply 5 & D for this
is some the way to go for black takes
takes white recaptures this is the way
you play for foreign advantage in this
position and in a recent game where I
actually had black the white player went
went takes on g7 and after shakes takes
the cheese sticks takes a very dull
position reist of course here white is
absolutely nothing but black you cannot
do much as well ok but be take c3m is
the way to go if you want to play for
advantage Queen m6 and now on I to a3
which is interesting the odd way to play
this is actually deform and try to make
use of the center um neither three is a
tricky sideline which affect I played
myself a couple of times d 4 is also
possible to fight for an advantage but
my dear three has some some tricks in
five yeah now d for good transpose but
Bishop d3 this is the point of the night
move to delay d to deform and probably
play Bishop with fabien before that
Bishop g4 this is very rare here black
normally plays 96 so Bishop d6 this is a
very rare move this should be fun yeah
and now we see why Bishop g4 only am not
played so often it's not terrible but
the instant problem is that bees have
knees hanging anthem how how do you
protect it if you play a mechanical move
like 96 then the move like will be 30
rugby one can get a bit annoying how to
protect us now
yeah black needs to play some really
ugly Ruth I guess you don't want to
cancel long and we have some rugby eight
probably but this is not much fun simply
castles and maybe default quickly white
will open up the positions to its
advantage so she played 97 which is
interesting just sacrificing this pawn
but still if you look at this Bishop d7
rupee 8 returns to d5 yeah this is
probably to provoke c6 and so it's how
to tolerate the bishop on d5 and now we
have this operation we are trading
everything down to an end game after
move 16 and here yeah what has mixture
bourne' but of course the porn
structures is rather ugly on the other
hand are black structure isn't great
either c6 ACM is also week and I'm not
sure that you really want to pawn on e5
probably you want it but it's not
brilliant for blog either what surprises
me actually if you look if you give this
position to a computer or like Houdini
I'm iccs got stock fish as the default
which are sometimes look at but let's
take Houdini which is the strongest
engine I'm pretty amazed that it gives
this position as completely equal this
is of course nonsense white is an extra
porn and black has no apparent
compensation for this of course it's not
the technical win but white is
definitely better with big strapon hard
to convert but upon us upon and like
certainly never will win yeah this is
the reason why white is better I'm
pretty surprised to look at the clock
times they played this very quickly
aronian actually meant with more time on
the clock then he started with maybe
it's a preparation but
for you who you found I mean if she
prepared this then I'm pretty amazed why
would you prepare know in an opening
which leads to a pawn down end game
where you have to suffer okay so on we
have from some fairly normal looking
strengthening moves for both sides and
this is the problem and the game will
continue and white always has this extra
porn and at some point in my tell of
course you don't see anything concrete
going immediately but in the long run
that's it is upon um in fact I am King
e6 bishop see 136 fo and here after a
form um yeah she simply made them made a
mistake probably a black in this
position needs to grab the pawn it
doesn't look I'm too attractive
admittedly because why then has got this
for four pawns him against to this also
applies for black four against two but
default c5c for this comes quickly and
with temple and blacks king is in the
mix also may be getting out of fire so
white is also better here but you need
to do this if you look at what she
played she played rugae six and now
white captured and now it gets it gets
really problematic the thing is some the
lawn looking move Bishop pigs in five
white just place this move and this pin
is actually decisive Black has no way to
save the bishop white threatening
default iphone and you have no way to
save it king here Chief Justice you
check and and it's over and came here
check out see five cheesy form and again
it's it's curtains this evening
checkmate direct made
so you cannot capture with the bishop
and if you cannot capture with the
bishop what should you do yeah probably
she needed to take with the king which
looks completely bonkers but it doesn't
seem to lose out right it's better for
white of course c5 should back check
check and yeah white is clearly better
probably winning but what is the
alternative what she did in the game is
she took here and after King you one
they're simply a double attack and black
is a piece down and quite surprisingly
she didn't resign but played on a couple
of moves check yeah but okay aronian is
winning this if you wake him up at 3am
at night and probably even without
opening his eyes check okay so a couple
of moves later she resigned sometimes
you just just so disappointed by your
performance that you forget to resign
it's a it's human check at certain
suddenly should resign somewhat earlier
okay 40 moves done and like resigned um
yeah frankly speaking um I don't really
get the opening here why would you enter
relatively m yeah it looks like
willingly into this into this end game
which certainly offers a pretty decent
drawn chances but I mean you're playing
against someone 200 points better than
you end with the brilliant and gameplay
and why would you um set up yourself
into this kind of torture position I'm
not sure okay so she lost this game and
aronian caught up a bit with the leaders
alright so next game Caruana against la
meet and caruana certainly am trying to
win he didn't have a great tournament
and now me sticks to his [ __ ] on defense
and Cara wanna play c5 this is his main
weapon against the CARICOM Bishop f5 and
h4 this is an interesting line and some
line that i can recommend to white
players if you look for some interesting
way to combat the CARICOM this is a good
idea after h5 which is the main move
right place c4 and this leads to a
complex strategical battle h6 this is
played here below me is answered by g4
and this can get very sharp if black
would reach reach here because of those
six ideas try to attack on the Kings
side usually a black place this move
also played by la mia in the game and
then wide place at age 56 f 4 which
looks funny because white only place
with response but he's got a huge space
advantage on the Kings side and it's of
course I'm very comparable to a French
defense but the French defense wear
white has already yeah won the bet from
the King side so to say but he needs to
be cautious as he's got nothing
developed and let's see what happens in
the game in fact I think what happened
here is kind of a model form for white
like when for a quick exchange of this
bed bishop okay winning a temple with 93
check yeah white supports deform with
night si si tu cheque y and Queen a five
and them okay I'm not one hundred
percent sure but i think we near five
sort of yeah it's the kind of move which
really admits okay and worse and i'll be
tortured for the rest of the game
probably i can hold or maybe I tried to
hold this position by
it won't be much fun the thing is if you
get the Queen's off white will have no
issue anymore with the King and just
have a look at this position just a
couple of moves later and there's not
much else that black can do I mean his
so this position um yeah this is simply
a one-way street where wide has got a
big space advantage and can try for ages
to press something out of this he's got
f5 as a potential break the problem is
in this kind of confirmation it's very
hard for black to move the porn on the
kingside sg6 would weaken the H porn f6
would weaken the e porn and the white
squares in general so you can never move
something there and yeah well white can
move and and f5 it's a problem and this
would who I'm sorry again even gain even
more space and black simply as nothing
you can just sit and wait and hope to
survive this somehow and this is pretty
much you get by force after you could
change the Queen's and I understand that
like and has got no big attack or
something that you can drum up quickly
but I think the Queen exchange simply it
leads to leads to very very one-sided
plane ok I'm back to this Bishop d2
whoopsie seven and nine th-12 as
mentioned right ones to prepare five and
here we go yeah it's ugly but what
should like do this is a flexible move
probably trying to double on the FR and
now f6 yeah black simply lose the sum
yeah patients here doesn't want to sit
and wait all the time which is
understandable um and yeah very human
you don't want to stay passive but
this certainly am let's leave a big
advantage white can take and here white
actually could take on e6 which is
probably even stronger than what you
played but what white plate is strong
enough 93 caverns g4 at XD five and we
see that actually wide simply get get
this pawn if I've looks quite
accommodating but what actually just
threatens to take on ethics and win win
the house with not f5 to come it's a
it's just ruined from like okay e5 with
relatively best tribe takes and he needs
to cover have six of course you cannot
capture here check this is a real big
Fork some takes and I g60 I white has
just a winning position in fact in the
game he am slightly spoiled it and let
back let black into the game this is all
fairly fairly normal the problem is
simply this dominating position of the
knight on d5 and the night on g6 black
can never move this bishop as it would
probably just get taken and white wins
the H porn yeah it's just a huge
pressure yeah here black actually had a
chance to get some play and this is by a
form the idea being after why it takes
and it's not so easy to suggest
something else then you've got the move
96 with this idea of a check on e4 and
also night to see form this um probably
a.m. black can continue to fight his
worse but he can fight on the game you
played a king e eight and now d 2 is
protected yep black simply cannot move
I would see here Kara wanna didn't have
much time so you played them played it
in a simple fashion as those end games
are also very good for white simply
because of the Nigeria gainst the bed
Bishop you can never play Bishop f8 as
white would take and take age six and A
five is also weakness so this is a big
advantage in the end game it's simply
though this wasn't intended should get
it now now it is gone this arrow it's
simply a difference in activity a bad
night just protecting the weakness g7
also bed and this all adds up to to a
winning endgame white can improve check
down now aged 60 just for check it after
Knight c3 why it has an easy way to
convert by just sacrificing here takes
and Bishop back and now we see that the
H poem decides because it is supported
by the night on g6 Black has no way to
stop the born in fact after this chick
couple of moves he reside after the nice
finishing touch g5 if black would take
now then there's 95 done this four wins
the game so I'm a pretty I'm pretty a
good game by Caruana is I think he
allowed a little bit too much in fact
after after this some he should really
win quickly but somehow he allowed a
little bit of counter play but it
probably never was so great for black
that he could could really save the game
um I just think that this structure is
too passive for black you you just have
to suffer on and on and you have no play
at all it's just not not attractive okay
so we got all games except except cards
on against kayaking and this is a long
game okay so let's start and yeah cards
and place all openings now going for g3
so we got them ready opening which is
quite funny because this is a line that
I play myself exactly like this and now
we captured on d5 it takes to 592 in
fact them in this position I'm myself
play Knight c3 or queen bee three queen
bee three mostly the idea is to attack
b7 and sometimes Queen B 6 can be
answered with this move and you get a
tempo on the Queen later so it's just a
little lulu move order an issue ok cards
are played Quincy tune there should be
793 and the idea of this setup for
widest you want to play you form and get
a position where you have an extra bone
in the center here ki can play Bishop
takes a three but what I'm talking about
is something like this castles and then
one would go a form and a position like
this I can actually get very sharp it
looks so harmless but it can get very
sharp because whites idea is to remove
the night probably if possible to deform
and then after preparation even play
f-4e 5 f-5 and use this for against free
majority on the King side so this is far
more interesting than it looks at first
sight but kayaking play Bishop takes f3
here seems to know the line actually and
because this is a very good way to
combat this it leads to an entirely
different structure 94 check and now we
have transformed to to a pawn structure
where ya white has got this central /
information which is and the bishop of
course this Bishop and cons protect each
other and secure the center white has
this long diagonal and he would like to
of course play am the B part up to be
five and open up this bishops diagonal
even more the thing is what black is
doing of course is a five blocking this
and said let's just advanced a couple of
moves we see what I'm talking about
likely managed to play the pawn up to a4
and of course this position is for black
am mostly um yeah something to to just
hold the position black cannot really do
much in terms of activity but this also
applies for wide wide also doesn't
really have a great plan for himself um
cannot really play the B porn as then
III would get very very weak so there is
frankly speaking not much going on cards
now tries to get rid of this Bishop he's
got to two bishops but the bishop pair
doesn't do much and um it's just um
trance some some moves yeah black I'm
interestingly enough didn't exchange the
bishop which I would probably would have
done but so there's not much going on
it's just it's just a pretty even
position like him did a good defensive
job and now transforms the pawn
structure
setting up this pawn chain yeah it looks
pretty pretty even yeah quite fun you
can do what trying to use the Queen here
yeah it's simply maneuvering so not much
happening now Carson tries to exchange
Queens and this is actually she accepted
and h5 yeah fairly typical move white
probably intended to play h5 themselves
or black locks this so yeah what is this
position itself it's just equal but we
see the game continues you don't need to
actually make a draw in an equal
position cars and just place on and in
fact it's also due to the time kayaking
was low on time obviously cards and has
lots of time left ya b3 he tries to do
something on the on the queenside and
probably without risking too much you
should have six yeah up to now I think
there's simply not much happening would
be six protecting King here king of 8
a-4 yeah ok probably introducing this
idea into the position and in fact this
provoked night 233 and as it turns out
this seems to be a mistake black
probably shut down just stay in the
position let's say King here and just do
nothing if white would play a five now
then you probably can just capture after
rook takes c5 the a porn is getting
strong
yeah this is saying but you win this
tempo and if white goes here then you
can play Knight c3 and this is entirely
different compared to the game as now
the a pawn is strong and the technical
implications and the game must simply do
not work you played this movements
mentioned and now Bishop f4 sir let's
play attacking the rock and what is the
problem the problem is the rook moves
and now III and this is somewhat
annoying now for black you cannot take
on only three of course as c3 is then
hanging let's say this kind of exchanges
of course usually favorable for right
and what exactly is a black am supposed
to do now it's it's really a problem
white also threatens to take on the form
which would be a very good
transformation as then the rook would be
free and let's say let's say black would
play nothing moves like this white would
take take and now can just play on let's
say Bishop c6 protecting a form and here
Y term enjoys an advantage she's got
everything protected v6 is weak and this
is some potential idea black gum has has
real problems too to keep this position
together this exchange on d4 was very
helpful so King g7 probably doesn't help
what he tried is the following if you
took on a form and this now leads to a
technical sequence Bishop g5 attacking
work and yeah where should this ruko if
black would play will create then
there's Bishop c6 and you don't really
want that it loses an exchange or piece
so not great and yeah where else the
only other squares is heaven and the
[ __ ] plate Bishop d6 in fact it's not
like em loose
in exchange Black has got an idea with
all this he played re5 attacking the
bishop and now forcing this this taking
on only seven in fact instead of b5
black could think about about 93 maybe
this is slightly tougher but okay I
don't want to to make the video is
getting long long anyway I wanted to
make it quicker but didn't manage okay
I'm this is probably a bit of bit
tougher but very difficult very
difficult defense it's very easy for a
person like me and afterwards to look at
this and switch on and on an engine and
it gives you this kind of movement yeah
okay why does some still better but
black is better in terms of a defensive
chances but at in the game it's
difficult he played this move and this
leads to this natural tech check takes
takes and this was the idea [ __ ] rock
and and Bishop unfortunately this leads
to the following position a phone jack
need needs to regain the exchange which
is like Bishop check a check on a check
on the eight and then you should takes
yeah and now what is black am got here
it's simply a nightmare to to defend
this position maybe it looks some
harmless at first sight but if you look
at this a little bit deeper you
recognize that black has big problems
and this is due to a couple of factors
this paw information makes a you bishop
very bad it is simply yeah trapped
within the position it will never be
able to attack something on the white
side however White's bishop is very
strong once if I this nicely anchored
here and always puts pressure on a seven
like this and this confirmation also
means that white is got four points
against three so he's got the potential
to advance the pawns and maybe get some
passport on the King side um and all
this is completely passive for black to
defend this is really a nightmare we see
that in fact it goes on for quite some
time yeah if I've according to to plan
why do handsome approved the position a
bit and now starts to shuffle around in
fact I was quite surprised that Carlton
played check some winning try relatively
early I mean you could easily um also
play play more moves and and wait but we
see that relatively quickly yeah still
maneuvering here g4 he relatively
quickly went with this problem I mean
just ten minutes ago I 10 moves ago he
played you 45 so you could easily
shuffle 30 more moves and in fact I must
admit this is probably what I would have
done just showing black that ok you can
do nothing and I can shuffle till hell
freezes over but ok he plays g4 trying
to win win the game um like talk and age
five this was the idea a breakthrough
based on the fact that this Bishop also
has no moves so if white would be able
to take on g6 black actually here
probably needs to take with the pawn and
then why it has a great activity for the
bishop and he's got the e porn as a
passed pawn so this was the idea in fact
here black am can draw which the
computer shows instantly
which for a human dome is very difficult
to to do black actually could take on h5
which looks insane after f5 but the
point is black can simply play h4 h 6
check King g6 route takes f8 King f5
like just gives away to serve this piece
and starts counter play with the two
passports and in fact this is a draw but
um okay it's very difficult to to decide
on this kind of defense because if you
yeah if you make some mistake you're
you're completely lost the problem is it
is it is a drawer any what should should
why do let's say you would attack one of
the pawns then gives a check and if
white wants to try to win this is a
barium he would need to walk towards the
the rook yeah so like this and g3 it's a
very quick here now note that if white
would capture for example then g2
already wins for black this pawn will
promote now so white needs to be a
cautious even g3 and now it probably
needs to to do this and protect against
the pawns with the king but then it's
really a draw you must go here to check
you cannot go to h3 its cheek need self
made so back check and it's a draw but
this is of course very tough tough to
find this this sacrifice basically with
capturing in both pawns and kayaking
didn't didn't see it understandably so
you played a rookie ch1 and now white
could take now Carlton's plan works the
thing is why I was suggesting to shuffle
30 more moves that the idea is to get
flex clock down of course they play with
with increment in like 30 seconds but
especially if you won't if you don't
play with increment then g4 would be too
early you need to shuffle more to get
the clock down from black ok g4 takes
I'm sorry we were already already here
FTX g6 yeah now White has got the pawn
and has got definite villain chances
maybe it is winning already rookie 60
ideas to get at this pawn king who
should be five check check yeah here got
this pawn but now white just wins g6 and
it's simply quicker those pawns are
quicker and it's also a tack on on the
black king check check yeah and this is
simply a set-piece cannot cannot do
anything and white has a clear winning
plan just push those pawns on yeah rook
g8 is the threat so this is the only
move and now well white sets up a really
deadly discover check c2 and now I'm
white has multiple ways to win also e6
would would win the game but he played
the simplest solution check just this
rook check and getting getting this this
end game you need to be cautious with
this of course on opposite colored
bishops and two extra points it doesn't
always guarantee you when there many
positions were like could could draw
this but this is not one of them the
problem is that in order to draw this
you would need to get the king to have
eight you need to control one of the
promotion squares and black simply never
gets to fh because of the pawn
controlled cg 7 and the bishop controls
g 60 black never gets in front of the
pawns and this means it's over they
played them a couple of more moves it
wide simply is too quick antioch I
aachen resigned so I'm yet another win
form for Carlton out of a really nothing
position he is simply brilliant at those
I don't know I know how it does it know
the critical position probably is really
here where black went wrong with the 93
with some kind of sitting way to move
like King g7 probably a.m. it would have
would have ended in a draw but he simply
manages to keep the tension enter and
puts puts this enormous pressure on on
the defender g4 here yeah but it was
very difficult to to decide to take on
h5 was really really difficult and um
this this was the shots probably due to
draw the game but kayaking wasn't up to
it with limited time all right so this
means Carson took took the lead again in
this this tournament and actually had a
look at the remaining rounds and there
are five rounds left and he plays
Nakamura and also some of the tail end
us like la me and who you fond and if he
plays in this fashion like using all his
possibilities then I don't know what's
possible maybe he can score another like
two three four wins who knows it's
really a bit spooky what he's doing
alright thanks for watching I hope you
enjoyed the video I
managed to make it a bit quicker but not
much quicker simply cannot help myself
alright thanks for watching and I'll be
back on Tuesday with the next round
coverage monday is a rest day so don't
wait for a video all evening there
simply isn't around on monday yeah why